hi everyone and welcome to secrets and
serverless
2.0 i'm seth and i'm a developer
advocate at google cloud
in the past i've spoke about strategies
for managing secrets in serverless
environments
but a lot has changed since then so
let's dive right in
if you've seen the earlier versions of
this session you're already familiar
with this application architecture but
if you haven't
let's run through it very quickly
suppose we have a web application that
tracks the number of visitors
via a hit counter like a 1990s style
website at its finest
we only want to pay while our site is
being accessed
so we're going to leverage google cloud
run and its ability to scale to zero for
this application
but because our application can scale up
and down
we need to persist our visitor counter
in some external
persistent data store like redis
but our application needs to
authenticate and communicate with redis
so that begs the question how do we
securely provide the redis password
to our serverless application
that's the journey that we'll be going
on together today we'll look at three
unique and independent approaches to
managing secrets in serverless
environments
the first is via plain text environment
variables
then encrypted environment variables and
then finally with a centralized secrets
management solution
let's jump right into the first plain
text environment variables
plaintext environment variables are by
far the simplest architecture
we create a redis password and we deploy
it directly into our serverless
application by an environment variable
let's take a look at a demo of how this
works
all right let's take a look at our first
example we're going to deploy
an application to cloud run that puts
secrets
in environment variables in plain text
let's take a look at what this looks
like what we're going to do is we're
going to look at our deployment script
which i wrote to just clean things up a
little bit
we're collecting the ip address of our
redis instance
and we're getting the redis password
again in plain text
then we're going to build our
application as a container push it to a
docker registry
and deploy it to cloud run and you'll
also notice that we're using the redis
password here
vi and environment variable to cloud run
let's go ahead and quit and let's deploy
our application
so what this is going to do is this is
going to build a container push a
container to
our google container registry and then
it's going to
ask cloud run to deploy that container
with those environment
variables our application will read
those environment variables at start
time
and deploy them so we are pushing to
container registry now and then we're
waiting for
our cloud run to pull that image and
route traffic to it
and when this is done we will get a url
where we can visit
our service
great so i'm going to go ahead and open
up this url in a browser
great here it is and as you can see this
is a very basic website
that has a hit counter that's backed by
redis every time i visit the site
i increase the hit counter i can reset
the counter
but what happens if someone breaks this
site so you'll notice
the reset counter method actually
includes the couch that i can set to
and i can set this to a negative number
and the site continues to function
but what happens if i set it to
something like a fruit
well then my whole application crashes
and we're presented this very nice
helpful debugging page that's very
similar to what you would see in like
rails or django or any popular web
framework
we get a bunch of information about the
request but we also get the environment
and you'll notice in this environment
our redis host and our redis password
are available
in plain text
anyone with access to this application
you can visit this url right now in your
browser
you would have access to this redis host
and this redis password
hopefully this makes it clear why plain
text environment variables aren't a
great idea
great let's jump back over to the slides
hopefully that made it really clear that
you should not
store secrets in plain text environment
variables
not only do you open yourself up to
classifications of vulnerabilities
it's really not a best practice so that
really only leaves the other two options
encrypted environment variables or a
centralized secrets management solution
let's take a look at encrypted
environment variables
so instead of taking our plain text
secret and putting it in an environment
variable
we can instead encrypt that secret first
what that looks like is a human or a
machine
takes the plain text secret and they
give it to a key management system like
google cloud kms
google cloud kms encrypts that plain
text data and produces what we call
ciphertext or the encrypted secret
we then provide this encrypted secret as
an environment variable to our
application
this way the environment variable has an
encrypted secret
not a plain text secret when our
application boots
it communicates with google cloud kms to
decrypt the value
and then get the plain text but that
plain text only exists
in memory it doesn't exist in the
environment
given to the serverless application
let's go ahead and take a look at a demo
great our second example is going to
leverage google cloud kms
to encrypt the secret value before we
put it in an environment variable
then when our application boots it will
decrypt the value using cloud kms
and only store the decrypted secret in
plain text
in memory so if someone gains access to
the application
or the environment of the application
they would only see the ciphertext the
encrypted
secret let's take a look at what that
looks like the first thing we have to do
is we have to update our application
i've already written some helper code
that makes this easy
so we're going to leverage this kms
decrypt method that accepts the
ciphertext or the encrypted secret via
the redispass environment variable
and then we actually have to encrypt our
secret so let's go ahead and do that
we're going to run encrypt string and
this is going to encrypt the string that
we give it which in this example
is the redis password with a google
cloud kms key
i'm going to copy this to my clipboard
and then
we also have to update our deployment
script because instead of passing in the
plain text secret
we now need to pass in this cipher text
or this encrypted secret
notice that we're still passing in it as
an environment variable but we're
passing it in as the cipher text
now let's go ahead and actually deploy
the application
and again this is going to build and
push our container
and then we're going to wait for cloud
run to deploy this new revision
and then after the revision is deployed
the application should behave exactly
the same
because we only decrypt the secret at
start time and we only eat the
additional cost of decrypting that
secret one time
let's go ahead and jump back over so
you'll notice that the application is
still
erroring because we haven't fixed the
bad value in redis
but the redis password is now that
ciphertext
and because google cloud kms is guarded
by iam
identity and access management you
cannot connect to this redis host
using this redis password because you
cannot decrypt it
unless you have access to the cloud kms
key
no this is great but there are some
disadvantages to this approach which
we'll talk about in a second
great let's jump back over to the slides
so as you can see encrypted environment
variables do protect against the
immediate threat
and they're a great starting point but
there are some drawbacks
the biggest of which is once you deploy
your serverless application with an
encrypted secret
you lose centralized auditing and
visibility into how that secrets being
used
if that's a requirement for your
organization or security practices
we need to take a look at the third
option which is a centralized secrets
management solution
in this model the application requests
its secrets directly from a secrets
management system
so as a secret admin or a developer i
put my secret into the centralized
storage system
and as an application i request that
secret directly from the storage system
that centralized storage storage system
is responsible for
encryption decryption logging and
monitoring
all in one place
on google cloud our first party secrets
management solution
is secret manager we aim to be that
centralized secret store that provides
you that value of auditing and logging
and visibility
google secret manager is a new fully
managed gcp
product that provides a secure and
convenient method
for storing api keys certificates
passwords and other sensitive data
that you might need in your applications
and services
secrets rarely differ across cloud
regions
for example your twilio api key is
unlikely to change
if you move your app from us east one to
europwest 2.
for this reason secret names in google
secret manager
are project global resources
the resource uri in this example refers
to the secret name to my secret
in the project name my project even
though that secret
name is global the underlying secret
payload
the actual api key is still stored
regionally
for example in this slide you can see
that it's stored in us east 1
u.s west one and europe north one
but how does the secret data end up in
those regions
google cloud handles it all we do this
with replication policies and we have
two replication policies
for google secret manager for customers
who don't really have a preference where
their secret payloads are stored
you should choose an automatic
replication policy
with this policy there's no
configuration and google decides the
best place to put your secret
but if you're a customer that has a
requirement that your data exists only
in certain regions
you should choose a user-managed
replication policy and pick
the specific region or regions in which
you want the secret to be stored
regardless of which policy you choose
though
google cloud handles the replication of
that secret across all of the selected
regions
you don't have to run a cloud function
or kick off a nightly cron job
google is the first public cloud
provider to offer offer a fully managed
secret replication
across regions
now i have to admit i've been lying
up until this point i keep talking about
secrets but i'm actually talking about
secret
versions that's because all secrets and
secret manager are versioned by default
the secret is actually just a very thin
wrapper around a logical collection of
versions
the secret version is what actually
stores the payload
data and state in your applications
you can pin to a specific version or you
can use the latest alias to pick up the
most recent highest numbered version
note that latest is a floating alias so
if a newer version is created
latest automatically points to that new
version
seeker manager uses an api first design
so that means that anything you can do
by clicking buttons in the cloud console
or by running commands in your terminal
via gcloud
is also possible in your favorite
programming language
in fact we have samples in seven
different languages that allow you to
call and execute secret manager directly
from your serverless applications
you can do so in ruby or python
java.net or php
go and node.js
before moving on you might be a little
bit confused about
secret manager and key manager we talked
earlier and
the second example we looked at
leveraged google cloud kms
so what is the difference between google
cloud kms
and google secret manager google cloud
kms is a cryptographic
oracle system nobody including yourself
or google can extract the keys in that
system
google cloud kms provides an api that
does high-level operations like
encrypt decrypt sign and verify using
those keys secret manager on the other
hand
is a data storage system that saves and
allows you to access
secret material so while they both
involve encryption
and decryption secret manager is more of
a storage solution whereas cloud kms is
more of a crypto oracle
let's take a look at the different user
journeys to help you understand the
difference between these two products
with google cloud kms in order to
persist a secret we have to create an
encryption key
encrypt the secret with that key and
then store the resulting ciphertext
somewhere a file system a database or
in-memory
as we saw in the second example we had
to store it in an environment variable
google cloud kms does not store the
secret that's your responsibility
and it also doesn't keep track of how
the secret is used
after it's been encrypted because google
cloud kms is concerned about the
encryption
keys not the actual data that's
encrypted or decrypted
with secret manager when you persist a
secret with secret manager you give it a
name
like twilio api key and you give it the
value that you want to store
secret manager handles the encryption
and decryption automatically
as well as the replication across
regions for availability
when you want that secret back with
google cloud kms
you have to provide google code kms the
ciphertext
and then google cloud kms will decrypt
that ciphertext and return the plaintext
value
assuming you have the proper
authorizations to do so
to retrieve a secret with secret manager
you just access the secret directly by
name
example twilio api key if you're
authorized to access the secret
secret manager will return the secret
and its metadata
let's go ahead and take a look at using
google secret manager in action
our third approach is to use google
cloud secret manager
unlike google cloud kms google secret
manager actually
stores the secret material and you only
need a reference to retrieve it
let's take a look at what this looks
like again just like before we need to
update our application
so instead of pulling the secret from
kms
we're instead going to pull the secret
from
secret manager using this access secret
function
and like i said before this code is all
open source on github and there'll be a
link in the slides and in the show notes
so you can always take a look later
let's go ahead and save this
and now we need to actually create the
secret i've written a little script
called create secret that just automates
this for us
you'll notice it uses the g-cloud
command to create the secret the secret
is named my secret
and it has a value of super secret and
then we're granting impermissions on the
secret to our cloud run service account
because secrets are denied by default so
we have to grant access
let's go ahead and run this command to
go ahead and create the secret
and it looks like it failed because i
already created it let me
fix that real fast
this is why you never do live demos
something's always bound to break
so i've just deleted that in another tab
over here
so let's try that again we'll go ahead
and create the secret
and great it succeeded you'll also
notice that
it's creating version one that's because
secret manager secrets are automatically
versioned but we're just using the
latest here
as one example and then lastly we need
to update our
deployment script so instead of having
this big long
password from cloud kms we instead just
pass in the reference to our secret
which is my secret we'll save this
and deploy the application this will
need to rebuild the container
because we change the code it'll push it
to the container registry
and then it will deploy it to cloud run
and again it will use the exact same url
just creating a new revision
so we're just waiting for traffic to
route at this point
great and it's done and if we jump back
over to our browser and refresh the page
you'll notice that our redis password is
still um
my secret it's uh i'm sorry you'll
notice that it's now
the reference to my secret instead of
the plain text password
and secret manager is guarded by
identity and access management so our
application is retrieving this value at
boot time
storing the plain text only in memory
and if even if this debug page were to
be presented
an attacker would not be able to get
this plain text secret because they
don't have access to secret manager
and we can see that you know the
application is totally functional great
let's jump back over to the slides
so today's journey looked at three
distinct
patterns plain text environment
variables which
no one is going to use encrypted
environment variables
and a centralized secret storage
solution with google secret manager
in the past centralized secrets
management have required
upfront and continued operational
investment with google secret manager
you have a fully managed secrets
management solution
right on google cloud we're also
expanding integrations with other google
cloud products
in the future you won't even have to do
this environment variable dance
with cloud run or cloud functions or
other google cloud products
because we'll have first party
integrations to directly retrieve your
secret at runtime
now if you've come to earlier versions
of this talk you might be familiar with
bur glass
if you're not familiar burglas is an
open source tool for doing secrets
management on google cloud
it predates secret manager and it
largely influenced the design of the
first party product we have today
bur glass is a fully interoperable
solution with google secret manager
we actually designed it that way from
the onset
if you're already using var glass for
your serverless secrets
migrating secret manager is super easy
there's a new built-in command in bur
glass bur glass migrate
that takes the name of the storage
bucket where your secrets are stored
and automatically migrates those from
google cloud storage
to secret manager keeping their existing
names and permissions
then in your application simply change
the bur glass reference
to the sm reference which is short for
secret manager
and redeploy your application that's
actually it
bur glass is completely interoperable
with secret manager and you don't have
to change your workflow to use it
best of all you can mix and match you
can have some secrets that come from
burglars and some secrets that come from
secret manager
all using the same unified api
thank you so much for coming on this
second secrets and serverless journey
with me
hopefully we've made it clear the
different secrets management solutions
on google cloud and how you
can best secure your serverless secrets
in your serverless applications